Hello. It is July 7,
2022. It is cohort One textbook
group week ten, chapter five.
So we're having the first discussion of
chapter five. We'll have two weeks of
discussing chapter five. Then in our
last two weeks of July, talk about
more general thoughts that we have on
chapters one through five and look
forward to the second half of the
book here.
There's two new columns.
This first one is if you'd like to join
for chapters one through five, cohort
two beginning in September 22.
And that will be in parallel with also
this first cohort continuing for
chapters six through ten. So just put a
check mark if you want to stay in.
Otherwise we won't include you in that
cohort.
Okay, so there's
only a few questions prepared for
chapter five. So let's start with any
general thoughts that
people had about chapter five, like how
is this chapter similar or different
from the previous ones? And what is the
function of chapter five here?
Or what did they think was an important
overall aspect of this chapter?
And then of course, anyone who can
capture questions that people are asking
here, just add them. But other than
that, it would be awesome to hear like,
what did people think chapter five was
doing or what did they wonder about the
material or related to it Ali
and then anyone else?
I think chapter five needs
a lot of Neurobiological background and
without necessary requisites,
it can be probably Daunting chapter.
And unlike other chapters, which are at
least the previous chapters, which
concern themselves with mathematical
formalisms, here in chapter five, for
the very first time we encounter some
empirical evidence or
the empirical reasons behind
modeling active inference as such.
So it's a very important chapter in my
opinion, but at the same time, without
any prior Neurobiological background,
it could be a really daunting chapter as
well. Nice. Thanks for the
summary, Mike.
Yeah, it was an interesting choice to go
all the way to the human brain to
illustrate how some of these concepts
would map to biological systems, as
opposed to starting with more simplistic
organisms and kind of working up from
there.
Yeah, very nice point.
Any other overview thoughts and then we
can just scan through it and look at the
order of a few things and then continue
to write questions again as you're
hearing them or as you're just
wondering. But let's hear
any other general thoughts if anyone
wants to raise their hand and then look
at the order of the chapter.
Okay,
well, the chapter is titled message
Passing in Neurobiology.
Message Passing was brought up in a
previous chapter
in this box 4.1, in a formal
yet slightly nonstandard
notation without examples, just
generally the
quote. Anyone have any thoughts on JF?
Yes, I kind of disagree with the quote.
I think recently we've learned that
plants actually sense and act on
what they detect in the environment.
For example, certain trees when they're
being munched on by, say, like giraffes,
will emit molecules
that will disperse, and other trees that
sense these essentially an alert signal
will start producing compounds in the
leafs that make the leaves taste very
bitter and thus discouraging foraging
and so forth and so on. And also, I
think it's clear that plants sense and
act, respond to their environment and
act in order to maintain their integrity
or as individuals or as as
groups in the example I just mentioned.
Nice. Agreed.
Also, the quote might have, like, a
little bit of hyperbole comedy,
like two types of animals,
plants. So it's about
nervous systems. Ali.
Yeah. And one other thing about Rodolfo
Linus is in one of his most famous
books, eye of the Cortex from Neurons,
the Self, actually, he describes
thinking as an internalized movement,
and it's a very interesting way to
describe thinking, in my opinion. And it
directly relates to this active
inference framework. So putting
his quotation here might be quite
relevant. Cool. And then I added 2017
paper with Friston and Calvo about
plant and predictive processing
framework. And then here's, like a non
active paper, but about more on the
behavioral side, which is kind of the
view from the outside without denying
the view from the inside as well. But
it's just related to behavioral
modeling. Okay. In the introduction,
they write, let us take a step back from
the technical material of chapter four,
which, as Ali and others have reminded
us, was like, even at the beginning,
was like, you can bypass this chapter if
you don't want technical detail. So
maybe somebody had read it, even 1235,
and maybe they did or didn't. Look at
the appendix. Turn to the process
theories accompanying active inference,
drawing a distinction between a
principle and a process theory.
Does anyone have any thoughts on that?
Like how, as they're reading the book,
are they thinking about where free
energy principle is related to active
inference? How does introducing
that kind of broad map territory
principle process distinction
here help transition the book towards
focusing on these empirical cases?
Ali with a hand raised or anyone else?
Okay, just one yeah, go for it.
Yeah. Sorry. Just one thing I forgot to
mention about that quotation is an
interesting research has been emerging
that kind of bestow
consciousness to plants as well. One of
the articles,
one of the early articles for that is
insights into plant consciousness. So,
in fact, we don't necessarily limit
it to just human or even animal
consciousness. And we are beginning to
relate consciousness or any other
aspects of nervous system to plants as
well. So just one additional remarks
about that previous code. Sorry.
Yeah. And the mathematical frameworks
for behavior and consciousness that are
integrative will allow comparisons of
different kinds of behavioral systems,
and then that leads to people wondering
about consciousness and all these other
areas. So mike and
then anyone else?
Yeah. So tying that back to the
part of the chapter that you were on
previously in terms of moving from
principle to process. And you had
highlighted that the latter allows us to
develop hypotheses that are answerable
to empirical data. So I think this is
the first instance in the book where
they are making a
serious effort to tie out to real world
observations as opposed to saying,
here's a framework for how things might
work and how the pieces might be
connected. Now we're going to take that
framework and think about can we
identify things that we see in real
systems, in this case in the human brain
and tie those back into the ideas that
we put forth previously.
Thanks. Totally agree. It's like
partitioning off the principles from the
earlier chapters. Like in principle,
those two sides of the equation are
equal because of how the axioms of math
are. Or like in principle one could do
this with a Bayesian graph and then that
is like in principle you could do a
linear regression with a least squares
error minimization. Nobody can make any
data set that says that you can't do
that. And then there's how that least
squares regression works on empirical
data. So they're saying for chapter five
we're going to look at with all
the architecture, developed a few
specific neural systems and talk about
how they're the best current
understanding that they have of how
these neural systems can be modeled with
models of the structures like we've seen
before. And they're
saying, we're not trying to write a
neuro textbook here, but to touch
kind of like with both feet, the
empirical modeling.
And then the systems that they are going
to model are like effector systems.
So motor control subcortical structures
like the thalamus and basal ganglia.
So these are more like functional
outcomes of the nervous system.
Specific anatomical structures of
interest, modulation of synaptic
efficiency or efficacy, which is like a
micro anatomical or like a
neurophysiological mechanism of
interest and something that is an
important, like, leverage point and
something that is being modified and
found to be changed in different
situations. And then the
relationship between decision making and
movement generation, which is also
something that has come up in those 46
live streams on like motor active
inference, decision making, active
inference.
Let's check if there's any questions
written.
Okay.
What could anyone say about the cortical
layers or what was in figure 5.1?
Mike. I was
just observing that in the
start of chapter four, they said, well,
you can skip this chapter if you don't
want to get deep into the math. And then
here we are at section 52 in chapter
five, I think, and they refer back to
the message passing structure
that was set up in chapter four.
Yes, good point.
And it's like, well, if you can skip the
details of the formalism to look at the
examples or you could skip the examples.
Any linear text, 140 characters
or textbook or a live stream or
anything, it's always going to be some
sort of linear presentation question.
And with a densely linked and
interdisciplinary area, then the
linearity becomes challenging. So maybe
with more with some notebooks or
some other rendering or educational way
to have the ordering or have,
of course, the connections between
sections be a little bit different.
The first system that they're focusing
on is the cortical column. Does anyone
have anything to add on cortical layers
or the role of the cortex, even if it's
just something that they've heard about?
Well, I think that this Menta
line of AI and many
of the other Ali go for it. Yes.
I want to say that for
the past couple of decades, or probably
several decades, cortex has
traditionally been thought of as the
seat of both consciousness intelligence
and also, of course, cognition. But
recent studies have shown that
especially studies such as
Mark Som's research has shown that in
fact, consciousness actually stems from
literally the brain stem, not
necessarily the cortex. So there are
some challenges about the exact function
of cortex, and the
debate goes on.
Nice. Okay, here's a little bit on the
cortex. So it is the outer frontal part
of the mammalian style brain.
Insects don't have cortex,
though they share a lot of the same
architectures and so on. So this is like
neuron tracing. And there's kind of two
levels of organization that people are
modeling in the cortical models. The
first is based upon the histological
observation of the layers.
These are six layers of cells, and
there's a lot of development and all
different functionality between the
different layers. One important thing to
note is it's not that they're like the
layers of a Bayesian hierarchical model.
It's not like each one is like up and
down, up and down. So this isn't like a
predictive processing architecture
happening simply with these six layers.
This is not a six layer model. In fact,
they're connected to each other sparsely
within a column, as it's shown here in
5.1. So that's like the micro anatomical
structure of the cortical column. And
it's called a column because it's like
the layers are also arranged in this
repeating way. And there's just like a
lot of different layouts for
different regions of this cortical
tissue type. And in certain situations,
it is organized like linear call
nerve structures, which is often seen as
one of the evolutionary local maxima
of depth of processing and sparsity
of connections laterally. So those are
the two levels of analysis that are
being and as early mentioned, people
yes, have gone to the consciousness
angle or they've just argued that this
is kind of like the massively
paralyzable, but also like deep
recurrent contextual, et cetera.
The anagrams like the patterns that
could be activated. The dimensionality
is potentially super high, so it could
play a role in memory signal processing.
And the two levels that people look at,
the connections between, like,
anatomically by taking these images or
by doing like, stainings and stuff.
Anatomically and functionally is within
the column where there's certain kinds
of relationships, and then across
columns where there are certain kinds of
relationships.
Any thoughts or questions on that? But
that's just why the cortex is being
studied. And that's like a little bit of
how the neuroscientists have been
approaching this and why this is one of
the important systems with a lot of
theoretical modeling and empirical
evidence and relevance as well.
JF I remember
many years ago taking a course in
physiology on the visual cortex and the
whole notion that the brain has some
kind of structure. Always thought it was
fascinating because I feel that the
brain is a huge hack, patches upon
patches upon patches, broadened by
evolution and that there would be some
structure in it is
interesting. But within those
structures, this picture shows
it's very messy. I would never implement
a system with this kind of wild
interconnectivity. So I'm
very curious about how much we can
infer from what is really a
mildly structured but highly messy
architecture in terms of process theory
that we're trying to elucidate
from anatomy and the functionality of
the brain. Nice. Thank you. Mike.
Yeah. That makes me think that some of
that messiness is in support of
redundancy. And so how do we think about
redundancies in systems in the context
of active inference?
Yeah. And like, neural systems, of
course, have amazing, in some
dimensions, ability to have redundancy.
Other times, seemingly, there's points
of failure. Jeff okay.
All right. So just on the left side
sorry. On the comment
about redundancy. I agree. But it's
worse than that. Every part often
plays many different roles and
participate in different functions,
which makes it quite a tangle in terms
of functional analysis of parts of the
brain and what they do and whatnot.
So five one is showing a
more like pure Bayes
graph with
the annotation of the kinds of cells
that are in the anatomical layer. So
this is like a visualization of the
anatomy based upon the regions that it
connects, gets inputs and outputs from,
and then the micro anatomy labeled
according to cell types. Then with
a similar but not exactly concordant.
There's not a statistical test proposed
for how concordant these are. It's not a
statistical argument. It's not exclusive
of other framings of what this anatomy
is doing. Here are labeled with
different parameters from the Bayes
graph architectures that have been
explored in the previous chapters,
compatible with message passing
implementations that other papers have
addressed that aren't here. These are
like architectures that recapitulate
some of the functional and macro,
structural and microstructural aspects.
So this is like computational
neuroscience, and it's using
these models that actually have an
underlying structure that is providing
utility and interesting reframings
of the anatomy.
And as the model statistical
architecture begins to recapitulate
aspects of the Cyto architecture,
there's like no specific threshold where
it's like, oh, well, now it's like an
argument that it's doing that function.
Like people get tantalized
by it having some, oh, well, we made
this network structured like a brain,
or we made this network structured like
a mushroom, or we did the ant colony
optimization. So just because
this works for what it does, doesn't
mean this works for what anyone wants it
to do. It's just in this huge space of
bioinspired model architectures.
In five,
two, they move a little bit from the
consideration of the columnar
architecture, which are cell
populations, to looking now
like still the superficial to deep are
the six layers of the cortex. But now a
few of the variables are highlighted and
their relationships. And so the
ascending and descending prediction
error in a predictive processing
framework which is often graphically
seen going up and down, bottom up and
top down effects. Here is being
shown in the context of the columnar
cortex where like errors
from one. Let's just go to where they
the E's are the errors and
the G's are predictions and
I guess we can find out what Mu is. But
basically, like, this architecture
within and between columns could
be like this being like the base
variable being estimated and a
hierarchical nested model of that. And a
hierarchical model of that. So there's
like a generalization statistical
architecture that has compatibility
with the neural architecture of the
brain and it does like a pure
statistical function. And that pure
statistical function has resemblance
with some things that the brain region
is believed to do. So that
allows this statistical model to be
explaining and predicting and useful
about the brain, which is like what
computational neuroscience does.
So that was the first one
of the systems that they focus on then.
Yeah, I guess this was then
the factor systems. Okay, let's see if
we can kind of quickly look at all the
systems.
What did anyone see or what would
they like to say about figure five?
Three neuroanatomy associated with
active inference in modulating spinal
motor reflexes.
Okay, so five one
was the columnar architecture and that
was described in terms of what cell
types were in it. Here they're going
to pick up on one of those cell types,
which is like the computational role.
The expectations encoded by this
cell type that's found in this layer
of the motor cortex. And so different
regions of the cortex have different
apparent functions asterisk,
asterisk, asterisk, but there's like a
visual cortex and a motor cortex and so
on. So this is in a motor region of
cortical architecture that plays a
certain biological function.
The expectations are subtracted from the
incoming proprioceptive input in
the horn of a spinal cord. This is like
lateral cut through a spinal cord. The
horns are like the butterfly parts.
And so there's a difference in between
the incoming intensity of proprioception
and the brain expected expectations
and then the error drives muscle
activity in the direction of
suppression. So the motor activity is,
like, reducing the divergence based upon
the sign and the intensity of
the compromise between the brain's
expectations potentially arising
within, like, layer five from these bet
cells and the incoming sensory
information, which can be modeled as,
like, why?
I think Mu is probably the mean of that
expectation.
I don't know what part it was mentioned.
And then here's the expectation, the
difference between these two. It's like
a causal system flow, but, like a little
different. You're getting a five out of
ten pressure, you're expecting a five
out of ten pressure. The motor reflex is
not engaged. You're getting a seven out
of ten pressure, you're expecting five
out of ten. There's, like a negative two
difference or whichever way you want to
be subtracting, there's like a two or a
negative two difference. And then that
triggers some motor neuron units to
fire. And then that proportionally
brings the expectation
into alignment with the measurement.
Um, they're gonna just like that example
hinged from a cortical layer. And cell
type here is going to be hinging
on the cortex and looking to an output
region of the cortex,
which is the striatum. And then they're
going to do a more detailed model of a
basal ganglia because it's been modeled
a lot more and then also have, like,
just a textual treatment of the
thalamus. There's multiple
papers on dopamine and
active inference and
so from 2012 and then
2015. This is a really
interesting area of research with
Dopamine because Dopamine is,
like, classically described as the
reward molecule. More reward, more
dopamine, lower reward, lower dopamine.
So isn't the whole
meme inactive that we replace the
reinforcement reward learning paradigm
with a different imperative that
has elements that reflect pragmatic
value, but that isn't the overarching
imperative for policy selection. And so
these papers show how, like in the
context of a generative model with
expectations and preferences and
Dopamine signaling something related to
the predictive processing of stimuli
under a mildly optimistic
world model, good events and surprising
events are still associated with
Dopamine release.
And things that are going worse than
expected are still associated with
Dopamine drops. But that
actually is, like, a more unified way to
talk about Dopamine's empirical outcomes
as opposed to the reward learning,
which has to hypothesize all of these
modules that translate different kinds
of things into reward. Jessica.
Yeah, I think similarly to these I don't
remember where I read this, but the
brain in regards to the dopamine
comment, it's also, like the
anticipation of doing something
and the fact that you're going to get
that Dopamine kick.
Basically, you get a release by
anticipating something. And that maybe a
little bit connects also with the active
inference, the fact that you are
anticipating something. You expect that
to happen. And so you get that release
of the dopamine in anticipation of the
event happening. I don't
know much, but I'm thinking it could be
connected with having a predictive
unexpected free energy or something.
Nice. Good insight, Rohan.
Yeah, well,
I'm not a biologist, but okay, so I just
want to clarify. There are other systems
in the body apart from just the brain
alone, right? So you have like the
autonomous or what is
it, parasympathetic nervous system that
controls your heart rate, your
aspiration and other things.
Also you have stuff like adrenaline and
noradrenaline that do produce responses
and other hormones also that produce
responses like for hunger or
satisfaction. And we basically have
figured out how to modulate these things
to solve modern issues for things
like obesity or something like that.
And there are treatments available that
modify these hormones levels. Right. So
is this not a very limiting perspective
to look at dopamine alone as the only
thing? And my other question would be
how does that convert into, say, motor
commands? So I just increased dopamine
levels without any stimulus whatsoever.
Let's say someone's taking a drug. It
would. So that does not necessarily
translate to a motor command. Right. So
how does it do this? Is there like a
specialized system that figures out
okay, so here's the previous action
here's increase in dopamine and here's
how we modulate to further increase
dopamine. And where exactly do you set
limits on this process?
Okay, the two questions were about
interacting physiological systems and
the second one was about dopamine's role
in motor selection. Blue, go ahead
if it's related or if you want to
address anything. Yeah, no, I just
wanted to respond. The dopamine response
is there are a lot
of interactions that are happening in
the nervous system. Dopamine is one of
the best understood, I think it's one of
the ones that we've studied for a long
time. And if there's an
overload of dopamine, the action can
actually be nonspecific. And that's what
we see in Parkinson's. Right, so it's
like an overload of dopamine into that
system and it fries it out and then you
get nonspecific action in
the nervous system, motor action,
the tremors and stuff. Yes.
Good call. And that question about non
purposeful behavior and dopamine on the
positive and on the negative, like
failure to engage, initiate action
relating in like catatonic behavior and
then like hypermotor activity associated
with repetitive motions of
various kinds. Dopamine is
known to be different in people who are
experiencing that differently and
modified by drugs that target that
system. But to the first question about
pluralism with respect to physiological
systems, for sure this model does not
exclude that, in fact, its flexibility
is its advantage because the inputs to a
brain region now we could say, well, at
this time scale it's electrochemical and
at this time scale it's going to be just
noradrenaline. And someone says, well,
how could you only model noradrenaline?
Say, okay, let's look at the model with
Noradrenaline and this other one and an
unmodeled component so it will
allow integration formally of
physiological mechanisms that genuinely
interact and as to why people write
like, specific papers about specific
hormone systems. It's just like what is
chunked off in that fractal? And then
also one important note is like,
Colombo and Wright have written about
how we don't need a monolithic theory of
any neurotransmitter or any brain
region. There might be like, features or
components of Dopaminergic systems that
it just explains and predicts that they
do reward, taken lightly, that the
explanation is just, of course, our
explanation of a biological system.
And also you raise like, beyond the
brain there's also glia and other cell
types. So, yeah, the cool thing would be
a framework where we don't a priori
exclude factors that are important, but
just to kind of go quickly through the
example and get to that motor action.
So this is an output from some putative
processing that happened in the cortex
and now it's projecting into some
Dopaminergic regions in the subcortical
area, like the basal ganglia.
It's going to be a model involving
outcomes. O, the difference between the
preferred and the expected outcomes.
The sigma squiggle expected free energy
evaluated for a policy and the posterior
over policies. The bold pi the
figure is like shown after a lot of the
description, but here
is where they refer to the high and low
Dopamine state. So also the movie book
Awakenings is about people who have
atypical Dopamine signaling and then
they're given L DOPA and they come and
get reinvived with life and stuff.
Rohan.
Yeah, well, this is a
little more general, but okay, so we
have the Marco blanket and there are
some internal states. And the Marco
blanket basically connects us to the
external states. Right. Or samples
from the external states and then
modulates the internal states
accordingly. Okay,
so my question is, I think if
the first imperative is survival
and the first imperative is to keep this
system in homeostasis, which is composed
of multiple interlocking and interacting
complex components, right?
How exactly would you translate these
multiple signaling modalities with
multiple hormones into maintaining
homeostasis with something like free
energy? Because some of these things are
compatible entirely. You would have
to have some sort of translation
mechanism. Right? So let's say that
adrenaline is jumping really high and
into dangerously high levels, but we
only know it's dangerous because there
is some system that is able to predict
that. Okay, it should not go above this
level because it's going to screw up
something else in the system. Right.
Multi scale optimization and not over
optimizing one lower level parameter at
the cost of some higher order parameter.
Yeah, but then you come to the curse of
dimensionality. So how many different
things are you going to take up before
it comes completely useless?
Absolutely. Good question. Empirical
question about what computational
hardware, what measurement data sets?
What sparsity of system graph? What
extent of application of heuristics how
accurate you need that model to be in
the empirical setting. None of it in
principle addressed
by just the equations, all of it related
to how they're actually implemented at
what scale, just to quickly complete
through here though, this is about the
depletion of dopamine is being observed
creating this akinesia failure to move
and exogenous dopamine promotes
impulsive behaviors of multiple
different kinds.
This is what it looks like.
Dopamine, as again stated here is
balancing modulating the balance as a
neuromodulator between inferring what to
do and what not to do. And so these two
graphs, both of them are getting
outcomes from the cerebral cortex of
the observations expected under a
policy. So those could be considered
like predictions about future sensory
states here.
And the gamma is this uncertainty
that's being represented by Dopamine.
In this uncertainty function of
Dopamine.
In. The direct pathway, the policies and
the difference between the preferences
and expectations sigma squiggle with a
tilde are being evaluated as part of the
expected free energy of future policies
and that is resulting in the selection
of policies. So that could be like
thinking through all the chess moves and
then picking the one with the lowest
expected free energy. Here the output
in the indirect pathway feeds into the
prior vector e habit and
then that influences policy through this
acting anatomically proposed through
this other region not defined with a
specific variable. So again, this is not
like saying necessarily even just what
it's doing. This isn't the full model.
The papers read more but that's like the
two pathways of action selection and
it's compatible with the empirical
evidence from pathology and from
pharmacology and genetic studies in
animals other than humans. And this is
how it could be modeled with a base
graph that recapitulates some of the
architecture and the function. Then they
describe the roles of some different
neurotransmitters that have been modeled
in active and
like what kinds of phenomena those
measurements have been used in
models.
And then one last important part,
it was in the section with the basal
ganglia that was talking about
this. So they show the graph of the
basal ganglia and then only in this last
paragraph do they describe the thalamus.
So just say we're just going to do one
paragraph on it but basically the
thalamus has these two divisions and
then they provide the interpretation
that these two divisions of the thalamus
could reflect first and second order
statistics on other types
of senses and policies.
So that's like a
unique prediction that potentially
modeling observed neural responses or
the bold signal from the blood oxygen
use in that region. You'll make
a better model if you fit into these
categories rather than reward or rather
than familiarity or any number of other
criteria. So just simply fitting better
is not the whole substance of validating
the formalisms described earlier but
it's part of the empirical grounding and
examples of unique predictions and
explanations. That are provided by
active inference. But that was the
thalmus part. And then in
this very short section 56, they talk
about how a lot of our interfaces are
continuous like sensory apparatus
and motor apparatus have continuous
aspects. But then in the
cognitive and decision making domains
there's often much more discreteness.
Even if there's multi scale discreteness
resulting in a very finely graded
continuum of alternatives, still there
is discreteness involved.
And this was explored a lot more
fully in the 46 live
streams. Active inference models do not
contradict folk psychology where they
really clarify. This is motor active
inference in the continuous domain.
This is decision making active inference
in the discrete domain. Here's what a
hybrid model looks like. Blue.
Oh, do I still have my hand up? Sorry,
just been up. Yeah. So then they just
basically say some of these models
dealt with continuous phenomena like
specifically the reflex arc example
hashtag active incontinence time,
figure four, three, et cetera. And then
other models presented in this chapter
are compatible with discrete
alternatives like discrete variables,
for example, policy selections. If
there's two modeled policy outcomes then
this is like a discrete model or the
observations could be happening through
discrete time. So there's like different
opportunities for discreteness and
continuous models and variables to be
integrated in
these architectures. Then in
summary, they're outlining the points of
connection between the message passing
implied by the generative models of
chapter four which we asked you not to
read gently, and the
neurobiology of inference, action and
planning. And then here is going to be
like a summary figure for the chapter.
The top row is showing some
computational motifs that are
plausible or compatible with different
subsets of cells and regions in cortex.
The bottom region are showing some
extracortical structures. On the left is
the basal ganglia shown from one of the
previous figures. So it's a subcortical
structure within the brain. Here is a
spinal cord cross section and
one can imagine that other structures
within the brain and outside the brain
would be amenable to also this kind of
graph and they're just doing like kind
of linking now even the models together
and then showing the difference in
planning. Like on the left side the
basal ganglia is getting this preference
difference is connecting to the expected
free energy. So future policies are
being, policies are being evaluated on
the basis of their future ability to
align with preferences. In this pathway
here that's planning habits are
when the preference versus expectation
difference but the outcomes themselves
are going to e and habits are
being followed which could be seen as
multiscale habits and that's influencing
policy. And then here's where that
kind of continuous decision and
modulated handoff
between more planning like and more
habitual is being related
to the motor implementation of the
expectations of the proprioceptive
loops. So like I want to be sitting
still and then all of your muscles in a
healthy situation are not moving versus
like, I want my leg again, speaking like
loosely with it. I want type word, but
just like, I want to lift my leg. That
model, the expectations have to be
updated to allow the leg to realize
being up using a non.
We don't have to say, well, it's more
rewarding for the leg to be up. We can
just say this is a computational
architecture that facilitated that and
generalizes to multi step planning. And
then there's been multiple papers 2017
and beyond that summarized and
elaborated on different aspects of this
more complex continuous architectures,
more complex motor and discrete
interfacing, more complex decision
making, active inference, of course.
Rohan.
Yeah, I'm just wondering because a lot
of this has to do with high level, more
abstract behaviors or kind of abstract
behaviors. Right. So is there any
attempt been made to apply this to
something simpler like the autonomous
nervous system? Because not every signal
goes through to the brain, right. Some
of them just go to the spinal cord. And
we know this because if the spinal
damage, sometimes people can't walk
or they have trouble rebreathing and so
on, or in other animals,
like the cuttlefish, for example, that
changes in the pigmentation of the
skin is not dependent on brain
movement, on brain activity. It's just
completely autonomous, right.
So has there been any attempt made
to apply this to much more
those kind of systems? Well,
how simple or complex a system is, is
kind of like how complexly we approach
it, because people have been modeling
single cell graphs,
if that could be seen as the simplest
electrochemical decision maker as well
as morphological computing.
And yeah, there's probably a paucity of
published models on autonomic
nervous system, active inference models.
So there are many opportunities because
they cited a huge amount of the neural
empirical work here, with the goal being
to summarize sort of the tip of the
iceberg. But there aren't models
like this for every single function or
region or anything, nor even if there
were, would it be the end of research in
that area. So, yeah, there's a lot of
open space to build specific models,
which is exactly what section six and
beyond and part two will take us to,
which is to go from, like, identifying
it, we can quickly find out whether it's
been published or not and then build
that model with the inputs and outputs
that people are seeing as relevance.
Rowan yeah, I'm sorry for
monopolizing this question time.
So I'm just curious, has this been
applied to non biological systems
in any way? Because that seems to be
something that we could easily do,
right? Because we have plenty of data
right now. Is there anything like a
better vision model than a convolutional
neural net, for example, or some sort of
swarm robotics attempt
using something like this or even like
game playing or something? Because I
would be interested to read.
Many of these things have been sketched
or are in progress. We have our project
ideas in these, like, last minutes.
There's a lot of room for
building projects, and there's a huge
value to creative ideation of areas
where it could be applied and also value
for checking literature for where it
might have been like a model could be
reused. Like a visual foraging model
that was from about cultural acquisition
of pattern preference was repurposed for
our ant stigma G model just by adding a
pheromone trace so there isn't like a
cookbook on what is out there or how
models could be modified. We hope that
with active block, for instance, and
documentation, it'll be clearer and
clearer for people to build generative
models and compose them and explore
different modules. So it should just be
done.
Yeah. Okay, thank you.
Any last thoughts or questions on
chapter five? And then next week, we'll
return to the more specific questions.
Ali, and then anyone else would like a
closing thought on chapter five?
Yeah, I just want to mention Thomas
Parr's speech.
I think it was a few weeks ago in center
for Cognitive Neuroscience, Berlin,
which I'm putting the link here in which
he explained most of these topics and
some more in perhaps more accessible
way. So if anyone wants to yes,
that's it. If anyone wants to watch it,
I think that can help in understanding
the content of this chapter.
Nice, thank you. Yes, looks like a good
one to watch. And using the same
figures, maybe we could annotate,
like the figures say, at this time,
step here's where it's described.
Okay. So those who want to, feel free to
stay in this room for tools.
Otherwise, thanks for joining and see
you next week.